soir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation jusque là en france sont 257
cas de couronnes un virus qui ont été
recensés quatre personnes sont décédées
les foyers se déclare un peu partout en
france on a entendu un ces mesures
prises par le gouvernement 10 millions
de masques pour les professionnels de
santé qui ont donc été déstocker
répartis dans toutes les pharmacies de
l'hexagone la vente des masques en
pharmacie est d'ailleurs désormais
soumise à une prescription médicale vous
qui représentez le personnel infirmier
es ce que vous avez le sentiment que
nous sommes prêts à lutter contre la
couronne à virus globalement c'est une
maladie qui est moins grave que la
grippe elle est un peu plus contagieuse
mais il faut savoir que dans 80% des cas
vous n'avez pas de pas de souci pour 15%
vous allez avoir une forte grippe et les
5% restants vont devoir passer par un
service de réanimation et 2% décéderont
est justement parmi ces 5 % qui est vont
devoir être prises en charge à l'hôpital
on est bien d'accord ce sont 95 % des
autres personnes portant contaminée par
le corps n'avait eu ce qui elles sont
invités à rester à la maison en
attendant que ça passe finalement pour
ces 5 % pour lesquels la situation un
peu plus compliqué très concrètement par
quoi est ce que ça se manifeste alors
c'est un syndrome grippal
après il faut tester pour voir si vous
êtes porteur de la grippe ou du corona
virus le souci que nous on à l'hôpital
c'est le manque de
le masque ffp2 les masques spécialisés
qui nous empêchent d'être contaminés à
notre tour pour ne pas contaminer les
autres patients parce que globalement la
maladie frappe principalement dans les
cas graves les personnes qui sont
atteintes de maladies chroniques et le
plus de 60 ans donc c'est les personnes
les plus fragiles
or nous à l'hôpital ce sont des
personnes fragilisées qui sont
hospitalisés et si nous on n'a pas de
masques ffp2 pour s'occuper des des
patients coronavirus avérée eh bien on
risque de contaminer d'autres personnes
donc là on voit qu'il ya une
impréparation du gouvernement et met le
gouvernement qui vient de prendre des
mesures et vont donc dans le bon sens
avec 7
ce déstockage et cette réquisition des
masques pour les personnels soignants
alors oui et c sont des masques
chirurgicaux les masques basique vous
voyez dans tous les films soient au bloc
opératoire tout et le sont pas
suffisants pour se prémunir de la
contamination
pas par rapport à malades avérés dans
votre vie quotidienne vous n'avez pas
besoin de porter un masque
et
sinon lorsque vous êtes la famille
proche d'un patient avérés mais les
gestes barrière se laver régulièrement
les mains et évitez de toucher cetera
c'est ça qui est important mais le
problème par exemple on parle d'un
passage en phase iii c'est à dire
utiliser davantage la médecine de ville
or là jusqu'à la ces jours ci les
professionnels médecins infirmiers de
ville n'avait reçu aucun masque là il
commence à recevoir des masques 50
masques par par professionnelle mais
sont des masques chirurgicaux qui
servent une protection basique mais par
rapport à un malade avéré ce n'est pas
adapté et donc là c'est un vrai souci
parce que s'ils professionnels de santé
devient à son tour contaminants que ce
soit l'hôpital avec les patients
fragiles où que ce soit auprès le des
patients qui sont dans les salles
d'attentes
c'est voilà là il ya un vrai problème
d'impréparation du gouvernement qui a
attendu fin février pour lancer la
commande de masques qui arriveront en
avril en avril avant là on est sur les
stocks stratégiques donc des masques qui
périment prochainement donc à vous
entendre la priorité aujourd'hui est
avant tout de protéger le personnel
soignant qui vient à l'aide des
personnes les plus malades du corps d'un
virus qui encore une fois on le rappelle
représente un tout petit pourcentage
parmi les 100 personnes qui pourraient
être contaminés du corps d'un virus
oui et c'est protéger les professionnels
de santé non pas pour pour eux mêmes
parce que les professionnels de santé
ils ont en général moins de 60 ans et
ils sont pas porter de grosses maladies
chroniques là mais c'est pour parce que
vont contaminer d'autres passions
fragile parce que par définition ce
qu'ils veulent en voir les
professionnels de santé
ils ont un problème de santé donc voilà
là la raison aujourd'hui au quotidien
comment est ce que le personnel
infirmier travail très concrètement au
quotidien à l'hôpital lorsque viennent
des personnes contaminées
alors pour pour l'instant les personnes
qui ont un état grave sont dans des
services spécialisés de maladies
infectieuses il a il ya assez de masques
ffp2 pour que les professionnels de
santé ne viennent pas contaminants leur
tour par contre si il y à une extension
de l'épidémie ce qui devrait se faire
ben ses services spécialisés vont être
débordé il va y avoir des personnes qui
seront hospitalisés dans d'autres
services
et là on n'aura pas les masques ffp2 à
notre disposition
à vous entendre vous avez un rein en
propos tout à fait rassurant rassurer
jusque là la situation est tout à fait
maîtrisée au sein des hôpitaux
comment est ce que dans ce cas là vous
vous interprétez où vous recevez 7
ce qu'on pourrait appeler peut-être cet
emballement parfois qui peut aller jusqu
à la psychose on entendait un seul
membre du gouvernement qui expliquait
qu'il ne fallait pas se ruer sur les
stocks dans les grands magasins que
jusqu'à ça ne servait à rien nous ce qui
nous interpelle le plus c'est que les
français sont assez réticents à des
vaccinés contre la grippe qui fait dix
mille morts par an et là il ya une
panique sur ce coronavirus qui est
certes plus contagieux mais dedans une
gravité moindre à part pour ces 2 % qui
vont décéder après on est dans un
phénomène d'épidémie qui se développent
et 2 % seront sur 1000 personnes bon ben
ça va tisser 2 % sur 10 millions ça
devient plus problématique
quant à la aux mesures pour revenir sur
ces mesures prises par le gouvernement
est ce que vous avez sentiment qu'elles
vont dans le bon sens c'est ce qu'on
peut encore limiter la propagation du
cornât virus limitée non non non
mais si chacun pratique gestes-barrières
déjà ça peut freiner et on voit bien
qu'en chine ça commence à abc
apparemment donc voilà par contre il ya
une impréparation et ça c'est un vrai
souci parce que si ça avait été un vrai
virus très dangereux genre rebela là on
aurait été confronté à un gros problème
parce qu'on n'a pas l'équipement qu'il
faut que ce soit à l'hôpital ou en
médecine de ville
un tout dernier mot vraiment très rapide
parce que le temps file mais pour
conclure
est ce que vous vous aller dans ce sens
là à savoir que l'on peut être
contaminée dans le corps par le corps le
corps d'un virus mais la situation n'est
pas dramatique pour autant on en guérit
oui tout à fait la majorité des
personnes ça se passe bien et on pense
même qu'il ya plus de personnes qui sont
asymptomatiques et donc ne vont pas
consultés et que donc beaucoup plus de
personnes seraient touchées
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos question terry à
montrouge rappelle que cette porte
parole du syndicat national des
personnels infirmiers et on retiendra
votre message rassurant
jusque là